دعت لجنه اطباء السودان المركزيه جميع
الاطراف لتحكيم صوت العقل ووضع سلاح جانبا
ومراعاه الظروف الاستثنائيه التي تمر بها
البلاد وطالبت في بيان جميع الاطباء
الاستجابه لنداءات اللجنه التمهيديه
لنقابه الاطباء بتغطيه طوارئ المستشفيات
بالقرب من مناطق سكنهم واناشدت اللجنه
جميع القوات بضروره فتح ممرات امنه لخروج
مرضى محتجزين بالقرب من القياده العامه
وفي نشره سابقه وصف اسامه ابو بكر المسؤول
في الهلال الاحمر السوداني محاوله اجلاء
طلاب مدرسه كومبوني في الخرطوم بانه
مخاطره كبرى
اذا عايز توصل للنازل بيوتهم بكل العاصمه
المثلثه هي الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري النيل
كل واحد هتوديه بيته محتاج تجهيزات سيارات
مختلفه
بالمناطق كثيره جدا في اشتباكات مسلحه
ونتواصل مع جهات الحامل السلاح
لموضوع الاسلام ده بيتطلب ترتيبات يعني ما
في منظمه المصادر ممكن تجهز طرق مركبات
توصل ال 450 طالب لاماكنهم